well special counsel Robert Muller's 448
page report on his investigation into
the 2016 Trump campaign continues to
make waves now just two days after a
redacted version was released Muller
concluded that while the president did
not break any laws he did try to stop or
influence the investigation members of
Congress are calling a Muller to testify
under oath on Capitol Hill and the first
calls for impeachment proceedings are
coming from some of the Democrats
running for president in 2020 President
Trump made clear his feelings about the
Muller report and some of his former
staffers on Friday we cha-chang is
traveling with the president she's in
West Palm Beach this morning we did good
morning good morning everybody president
Trump is spending this Easter weekend
with friends and family in Florida but
that chaos created by that Muller report
has certainly followed him here and now
he is on the defensive again with
Democrats demanding to see an unredacted
copy of the report and some political
rivals calling for his impeachment the
president tweeted his summary of the
redacted Muller report in all caps Trump
has been totally vindicated he also
lashed out over some of the statements
about him in it calling them total BS
and only given to make the other person
look good or me to look bad president
Trump's tone was much softer when the
report was first released I'm having a
good day too I was called no collusion
no obstruction mr. Trump is right that
special counsel Robert Muller found no
collusion with Russians in the 2016
presidential election but on obstruction
Muller wrote while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him CBS
News legal analyst Jonathan Turley says
Muller should have made a definitive
ruling after looking into ten events to
see if the president obstructed justice
it ultimately comes down to why those
acts were committed was this a case of
corrupt intent or was this just the type
of visceral reactions that we've seen
from President Trump in various areas
good morning everybody and I turn
General William bar ultimately
determined there was no obstruction
Moeller hinted Congress should draw a
conclusion though bar offered a
contradictory interpretation Special
Counsel Muller did not indicate that his
purpose was to leave the decision to
Congress on Friday House Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler issued a
subpoena ordering bar to release the
complete and unredacted version of the
report I see considerable evidence of
obstruction of justice which is what
Muller said
but many Democrats are hesitant to call
for impeachment impeachment shouldn't be
a fetish for anybody that would be
ridiculous but it shouldn't be a taboo
either it's part of the Constitution it
is the instrument of self-defense for
the people and the Congress the campaign
trail though is a very different venue
and Massachusetts senator Elizabeth
Warren became the first major
presidential candidate to bring up
impeaching the president tweeting
yesterday the severity of the
president's misconduct as outlined in
the report means that House should
initiate impeachment proceedings Anthony
these are thanks